[Musique]
bonjour à tous C'est alerte info est
consacré aujourd'hui aux avancées que le
groupe les républicains a obtenu cette
semaine à l'Assemblée nationale
lors de l'examen de nos propositions de
loin les républicains ont pu faire
adopter une proposition de loi
permettant d'améliorer la retraite des
agriculteurs en prenant en compte les 25
meilleures années donc c'est une avancée
très importante qui valorisera nos
agriculteurs dont vous savez que ils ont
une retraite modeste alors même que ils
font un travail considérable pour
nourrir la population la deuxième
annoncée notable et la loi anti-squate à
laquelle le groupe LR a contribué
puissamment faisant reconnaître ce délit
à la fois pour les locaux à l'usage
d'habitation et les locaux l'usage
économique désormais la loi protégera
les propriétaires contre les intrusions
et le maintien dans des locaux qui ne
leur appartiennent pas et puis la
troisième avancée très conséquente a été
obtenue hier soir de haute-lutte pour la
création d'une juridiction spécialisée
destinée à examiner les applunir les
violences intra familiales vous le voyez
les républicains sont engagés pour les
Français et chaque fois qu'ils en ont la
possibilité bien il faut avancer des
dossiers importants au bénéfice de tous
nos compatriotes
[Musique]